- 양자 정보와 계산의 이해에
오신 것을 환영해요.
제 이름은 John Watrous이고, IBM Quantum Education의
기술 디렉터예요.
이 시리즈의 목적은 양자 정보와 계산에 대한
탄탄한 이해를 제공하는 거예요, 그리고 그건 기술적인 세부 사항을 깊이 다루는 걸 의미해요
양자 정보의 기술적인 내용을 살펴보고 양자
컴퓨팅이 실제로 어떻게 작동하는지, 뭘 할 수 있고 뭘 할 수 없는지 알아볼 거예요.
이 시리즈의 개요 영상을
아직 안 보셨다면, 꼭 한번 확인해 보세요.
그 영상에서 이 시리즈에 권장되는 배경 지식이
어떤 건지, 그리고 다룰 주제들의 개요를 확인하실 수 있어요.
또한, Qiskit 교과서도 꼭 확인해 보세요.
이 영상 시리즈와 같은 내용을 글로 다루고 있어요,
그리고 여러분이 더 잘 이해할 수 있도록
하드웨어와 소프트웨어에 대한 인터랙티브 구성 요소와 인터페이스도 포함하고 있어요
양자 정보와 계산을요. 개요 영상과 Qiskit 교과서 링크는
설명란에서 찾으실 수 있어요.
이건 시리즈의 유닛 1의
레슨 1이에요.
유닛 1은 양자 정보의 기초를
다루고, 이 유닛의 첫 번째 레슨에서는 양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지에 초점을 맞출 거예요
단일 시스템에 대해서요, 즉
하나의 물리적 시스템이나 양자 정보를 저장하는 어떤 종류의 장치가
있고 그 하나의 시스템이나 장치가
독립적으로 어떻게 작동하는지를 살펴보는 거예요.
이 레슨 다음에는 여러 시스템이 있을 때
양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지를 논의할 거예요, 그리고 그것을 통해
여러 qubit를 사용하는
양자 알고리즘과 같은 흥미롭고 중요한 개념들을 설명할 수 있게 될 거예요
그리고 양자 정보를 처리하고
서로 주고받는 여러 개인이 관여하는 양자 프로토콜도요.
하지만 그런 논의에 들어가기 전에, 비교적
단순한 설정인 단일 시스템의 독립적인 경우부터 시작하는 게 맞아요,
부분적으로는 단순한 것부터 시작하는 게 좋기 때문이기도 하지만, 앞으로 보게 되듯이 양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지의 설명이
단일 시스템의 독립적인 경우에 대해 아주 자연스럽고
논리적으로 여러 시스템에 대한 양자 정보의 작동 방식 설명으로
이어지기 때문이에요.
레슨의 간략한 개요를 살펴볼게요.
먼저 고전 정보에 대해
이야기하는 것부터 시작할 거예요.
이 레슨의 목적은 고전 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지
설명하는 게 아니라, 양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지 설명하는 거예요,
하지만 양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지
설명하려면, 고전 정보부터 시작해서 양자 정보를 논의할 때 친숙한 참고점으로 사용하는 게 매우 도움이 돼요
양자 정보를 논의할 때요.
수학적 수준에서 양자 정보와 고전 정보는 실제로 꽤 비슷한 설명을 가지고 있어요, 물론 몇 가지 핵심적인 차이점이 있지만요.
사실 양자 정보는
고전 정보와 완전히 분리된 게 아니에요.
고전 정보의 확장이에요.
사실, 적어도 제 관점에서는, 고전 정보를
이해하지 못하면 양자 정보를 정말로 이해할 수 없어요,
그래서 고전 정보부터 시작하는 게
합리적이에요.
이 내용이 일부 시청자분들에게는
익숙할 거라고 생각하지만, 이미 익숙하시더라도 건너뛰지 않는 걸 권장해요.
양자 정보를 이해하는 데 가장 관련 있는 고전 정보의 측면을
강조하는 것 외에도, 이 부분에서 Dirac 표기법을 소개할 거예요,
이건 시리즈 전체에서
벡터와 행렬을 설명하는 데 사용할 표준적인 방법이에요.
알고 보면, Dirac 표기법은
양자 정보에만 특화된 게 아니에요.
고전 정보뿐만 아니라 벡터와 행렬이 등장하는 여러 다른 맥락에서도 동일하게 사용될 수 있어요.
그다음 양자 정보로 넘어갈 거예요, 구체적으로는
양자 상태의 벡터 표현을 논의할 거예요,
표준 기저 측정이라는 간단한 유형의 측정과, 양자 시스템에서 이산 시간
변화를 설명하는 유니터리 연산을요.
다시 말하지만, 모든 것이
단일 시스템의 맥락에서요.
레슨 자체를 시작하기 전에, 양자 정보에는 실제로 두 가지 설명이 있다는 걸 명확히 하는 게 도움이 될 거예요
양자 정보의 간소화된 설명, 이것이 이 레슨에서
집중할 내용이에요
그리고 이 첫 번째 유닛 전체에서요, 그리고 일반적인 설명은 나중 유닛에서,
구체적으로 시리즈의 세 번째 유닛에서 다뤄요.
간소화된 설명은 이름답게
더 단순하고 보통 먼저 배우게 돼요.
간소화된 설명에서는 이미 말씀드렸듯이 양자 상태는 벡터로 표현되고
연산은 유니터리 행렬로 표현돼요.
양자 정보에 대한 이 설명은 예를 들어
대부분의 양자 알고리즘을 이해하기에 충분해요,
그래서 지나치게 단순화된 게 아니라, 진짜예요.
하지만, 앞으로 진행하면서
발견하게 되겠지만, 몇 가지 한계가 있어요.
예를 들어, 양자 시스템에 대한 노이즈의
영향을 모델링하고 싶다면, 이 설명으로는 부족해요.